SICK-OUT TODAY BUT GOT THE
SUPPORT OF SOME DEMOCRATS.
INCLUDING ALEXANDRIA CORTEZ.
>> I AM GETTING MY HANDS ON ANY
HAND SANITIZER I CAN FIND.
>> Sandra: MY NEW JOB IS TO
STAY ALIVE FROM AN WORRIED
INSTA CART SHOPPER AS EMPLOYEES
AT ONLINE DELIVERY COMPANIES
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
PERSONAL SAFETY AMID THE
PANDEMIC.
STAGING WALK SICK-OUTS AND
TRYING TO GET BETTER HEALTH
PROTECTIONS AND MORE PAY.
ANDY PUZDER IS WITH US.
PARENT COMPANY OF HARDEE’S AND
THE CAPITALIST COMEBACK.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, ANDY.
>> GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> Sandra: YOU ARE AN IMPORTANT
VOICE IN THIS CONVERSATION.
YOU USED TO RUN THAT COMPANY
THAT OVERSAW ALL OF THOSE
RESTAURANT CHAINS.
YOU HAD WORKER ISSUES ALL THE
TIME.
SOME ARE CALLING THESE INSTA
CART SHOPPERS, AMAZON PACKERS
HEROES BECAUSE THEY’VE
CONTINUED TO WORK IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT.
THOSE INSTA CART SHOPPERS PLAY
A KEY ROLE IN HELPING THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE SHOP IN THE
GROCERY STORE AND LEAVE IT ON
THE DOORSTEP.
ARE THE COMPANIES DO ENOUGH TO
PROTECT THEM?
>> I THINK THE COMPANIES ARE
DOING WHAT THEY CAN.
LOOK AT THE PEOPLE AT AMAZON.
THESE AREN’T STUPID PEOPLE.
THEY KNOW THAT THE TWO MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS IN A BUSINESS
ARE NUMBER ONE YOUR EMPLOYEES
AND NUMBER TWO YOUR CUSTOMERS.
I’M SURE THEY WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING ONE, TO PROTECT THE
EMPLOYEES’ HEALTH.
IF THEY AREN’T PROTECTING THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND IF THEY ARE
ALLOWING THIS VIRUS TO SPREAD
IN THEIR FACILITIES THEY WILL
LOSE BUSINESS.
PEOPLE WILL STOP ORDERING FROM
THEM.
I’M SURE THEY WILL DO
EVERYTHING THEY POSSIBLY CAN.
THEY MAY NOT DO WHAT ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ WANTS THEM TO DO.
SHE WANTS EMPLOYEES TO GET PAID
AND STAY HOME 365 DAYS A YEAR
WHICH IS IMPOSSIBLE.
I THINK THESE COMPANIES WILL DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN.
I DON’T KNOW IF THEY’RE DOING
ENOUGH NOW.
THEY SHOULD BE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THESE DEMONSTRATIONS
BECAUSE IF PEOPLE GET AFRAID TO
ORDER ONLINE THEY’LL STOP
ORDERING ONLINE.
IT WOULD BE A DISASTER FOR THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW WITH THE
CURRENT CRISIS.
>> Sandra: IT’S AN EXTREMELY
VALUABLE SERVICE THAT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR COMPANIES
ARE OFFERING.
IN THE CASE OF THIS AMAZON
WORKER AT THE FACILITY IN
STATEN ISLAND, THERE HAS BEEN A
BACK AND FORTH TRYING TO REVEAL
WHAT EXACTLY HAPPENED THERE
BECAUSE WHY WOULD THAT EMPLOYEE
BE FIRED IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL
THIS?
THE FIRED WORKER PUT OUT A
STATEMENT AND SAID THIS, ANDY.
AMAZON WOULD RATHER FIRE
WORKERS THAN FACE UP TO ITS
TOTAL FAILURE TO DO WHAT IT
SHOULD TO KEEP US, OUR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITY SAFE.
I’M OUTRAGED AND DISAPPOINTED
BUT NOT SHOCKED.
AMAZON WOULD RATHER SWEEP A
PROBLEM UNDER THE RUG THAN ACT
TO KEEP WORKERS AND WORKING
COMMUNITIES SAFE.
AMAZON RESPONDED WITH A
STATEMENT SAYING DESPITE THAT
INSTRUCTION TO STAY HOME WITH
PAY HE CAME ON SITE.
THIS  IS UNACCEPTABLE AND WE
TERMINATED HIS EMPLOYMENT AS A
RESULT OF THESE MULTIPLE SAFETY
ISSUES.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF SO MUCH
OF THE CONCERN, PROBLEM,
COORDINATION THESE COMPANIES
FACE WITH THEIR EMPLOYEES TO
KEEP THEM SAFE BUT ALSO TO KEEP
THEM WORKING.
>> WELL, BECAUSE YOU ARE AN
ACTIVIST DOESN’T INSULATE YOU
FROM ABIDING BY THE COMPANY
SAFETY PROCEDURES.
IF HE VIOLATED THOSE PROCEDURES
THEY WERE FULL LEWITHIN THEIR
RIGHTS TO FIRE HIM AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE HE IS IN
THERE DOING EXACTLY WHAT HE IS
PROTESTING AGAINST.
SPREADING THE VIRUS.
I DON’T KNOW IF HE HAS DONE
THAT.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.
WE HAVE TWO VERSIONS HERE.
I HAVE HAVEN’T HEARD HIM DENY
IT IN ANY OF THE STATEMENTS
THAT WERE ISSUED AND I THINK
AMAZON PROBABLY ACTED CORRECTLY.
THAT DOESN’T MEAN YOU SHOULD GO
FIRING EMPLOYEES EVERY TIME
THEY SPEAK UP, EITHER.
THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM.
AMAZON NEEDS TO SOLVE THIS.
>> Sandra: IT IS QUITE A BACK
AND FORTH THAT’S HAPPENING.
I WANT TO FINISH WITH THE NEW
YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL STATEMENT.
SHE SAID IN NEW YORK THE RIGHTS
OF ORGANIZERS CODIFIED INTO LAW.
AT THE TIME WHEN SO MANY NEW
YORKERS ARE STRUGGLING THIS
ACTION WAS IMMORAL AND IMHUMANE.
THE OFFICE OF THE A.G. IS
CONSIDERING ALL LEGAL OPTIONS.
THAT’S A STORY WE’LL WATCH FOR
SOME TIME.
FINAL THOUGHTS.
YOU WROTE ABOUT THE BIG
CAPITALIST COMEBACK.
WHAT HAPPENS AFTER WE GET
THROUGH THE WORST OF THIS ON
THE MEDICAL SIDE AND SAVING
LIVES AND THEN WE SEE THE
ADMINISTRATION TRY TO OPEN THE
ECONOMY BACK UP?
HOW MUCH CAN WE COME BACK AND
HOW FAST CAN THAT HAPPEN?
>> WE CAN COME BACK VERY
QUICKLY IF TRUMP DOES WHAT HE
DID DURING THE FIRST THREE
YEARS OF HIS ADMINISTRATION AND
STEPS BACK AND ENCOURAGES
BUSINESSES TO HIRE.
LOWERING TAXES, REDUCING
REGULATION.
I HOPE WE DON’T MAKE THE
MISTAKE WE MADE AT THE END OF
THE GREAT RECESSION WITH THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHERE THEY
CAME IN WITH A STIMULUS AND
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT AND THE
DODD-FRANK ACT ATTEMPTING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A CRISIS TO
ENACT SOME SOCIALIST
COLLECTIVIST AGENDA.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE AMERICAN
BUSINESSES ARE FREE TO GROW.
THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GROW.
THE GOVERNMENT ISN’T
SUPPRESSING THE GROWTH AND
WE’LL COME BACK VERY QUICKLY.
TRUMP’S LAST THREE YEARS, THE
FIRST THREE YEARS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION WERE A PERFECT
ROADMAP FOR WHAT WE NEED TO DO
WHEN THIS CRISIS IS OVER.
OBAMA’S EIGHT YEARS ARE A
PERFECT ROADMAP FOR WHAT WE
SHOULDN’T DO WHEN THIS CRISIS
IS OVER.
I THINK WE CAN COME BACK
QUICKLY.
>> Sandra: THERE HAS BEEN
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR AT LEAST
THAT STIMULUS FOR NOW TO GET
OUT TO THOSE STRUGGLING
AMERICAN FAMILIES.
>> WE NEED IT NOW.
WE NEED IT NOW.
WE DON’T NEED IT WHEN IT’S OVER.
WE NEED IT NOW TO GET THROUGH
THIS.
NOBODY IS ARGUING ABOUT THAT.